hello and welcome to this video playing
a leg dorton anecdotal what is
maniacally water love to get them open
caesarean after all intern captions pose
to the dragon we're wide have committed
early on to some things should be three
and so on yeah I've got problems with
this mostly because I have no idea about
the theory I like doulton seems to know
everything and play since the nose yeah
yeah how do I play against this stuff is
really tough if you have no idea about
it night h5 route h5 is probably going
to kill me is it 9h fun now then he goes
Bishop g7 first we have to insert this
nine inch fun yeah probably in a line
that just lose this I'm kind of
suspecting that but okay I don't have
much choice now I have to grab okay and
yeah unfortunately I mean it's an
extremely annoying pin extremely
annoying pin and also some endings here
really really suck twin b6 yeah that
then that's what i meant either that
ending sucks it really does okay so is
there something I can do here if I move
the night you can take and check me
the cheek there you will probably catch
a long again I problem but we have to
drive this Queen d2 maybe and I'm not
sure that you will trade him even though
it might be good for him I'm not saying
it isn't but I cancer like yes before
now before yeah maybe so this one yeah
both rooks are hanging ok I can take
tool but the screen h6 and clean g5 so
that doesn't look all too great
yeah it looks very very very dangerous
nothing new them if I kick here I would
really like would really like to unpin
or force him to take if you would be
forced to take that that isn't that it
all isn't all that clear if he needs to
take but don't quite see how I can for
awesome Bishop Bishop to see six is
going Bishop me and especially six
taking okay let's take let's take yam so
now all kinds of stuff is threatened
group g 7 is the main threat and clean
age six time worry my god I'm just and I
saw that far too late yeah again we need
the dragon is an opening in one one
mistake and you're getting annihilated
and this has happened here are maybe
more than one mistake I don't know but
enough to lose the game ok yes late I
should get to fix that it's really
annoying with the message popping up and
I don't quite know why yeah so that was
pretty bad it was pretty bad yeah and
the thing is I'm even if it is entirely
incorrect for wide is super dangerous
and I did the didn't feel very
so what happens here let's have a look
Jen stop fish gives me five years that's
modern move that looks very reliable I
tried something similar that that that
might be already too late age 16 hour
winds I think actors on the board month
right ahead is on the board I remember
this yeah yeah yeah sure I had to solve
the board I'm losing I could have lost
for a second time to the same idea okay
I need to look at the look this lineup
and trying this out at the moment that
they don't have an idea it's a lots of
people plan to this instead of the
barrack see ya and the engine actually
believes i'm winning you have to be for
which up Slade and now Bishop takes b2
and wins you know what I did I simply
saw Queen g5 and and I have just f king
evade and he resides here in this
position so it didn't work at all not at
all and now i'm probably using yahoo FHN
and rook c8 would be better in
comparison right okay this it's a moot
point we should be to just wins I mean
you've listed everything out very very
quickly and it just didn't work we
should be two wins I completely I
completely did not register viene that I
can go King evade I mean I thought I
have to go back and that looked like
crazy up to I mean the pole itself is
rather unimportant like yeah I thought I
just use time and I didn't I didn't
really recognize that I can go to a face
which makes a huge difference and now
the look is hanging and I'm threatening
bishops III and songs if it takes here
g3 holy moly sat down anymore whoa know
that that I wouldn't have played
you
okay first of all and then does not work
yeah let's look HD so that we can can
exclude if i take here that's a draw
after 55 okay so i might really have to
do this I mean it it wins I'm just
thinking about the likelihood that
somebody would find it and somebody
would be mere proof yeah okay I mean
that doesn't that that doesn't work I
mean I that's it's really clear right
okay yeah it was blackmailing the answer
that was really bad let up want to play
the slant on sake time I have to have to
learn it ready the kind of the position
type is kind of the worst possible for
me because I don't like to get attacked
on the King like that this kind of
caveman attack it often doesn't work but
i'm notoriously bad at defending against
this stuff here should be two wins and
this just loses badly yeah p you have no
TF no defense and it is this group g7
threatened and queen h6 threatened and
everything so ok guys thanks for
watching